The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Good
morning, everyone.
So lecture three of four in the
shortest path module and today
we'll finally
confront our nemesis,
which are negative cycles
and negative edges.
And we will describe
an algorithm
that is due to two
different people.
They didn't collaborate
to produce this algorithm.
Bellman and Ford.
This computes shortest paths
in a graph with negative edges.
And not only that,
even in the graph
has negative cycles
in it, the algorithm
will be correct in
the sense that it
will report the existence
of a negative cycle
and, essentially, abort the
computation of shortest paths
that are undefined.
And for the few
vertices that do not
have negative cycles in
between them and the source,
the algorithm will report
correct shortest paths.
So it is a polynomial
time algorithm.
It's fairly easy to describe.
And what we'll do is describe
it, analyze its complexity
and, for once, we'll do a
formal proof of its correctness
to show that it reports the
existence of negative cycles
if they do exist.
And if they don't
exist, it correctly
computes shortest path weights.
So recall that when we
look at the general case
of the shortest path problem.
We're going to have, let's say,
a vertex u that, in this case,
happens to be our source.
And let's say for
argument's sake
that we have a negative
weight cycle like so.
So let me to draw this in bold.
And this happens to be
a negative rate cycle.
Let's assume that all of these
edges have positive weights.
Then, if you have
an algorithm that
needs to work on this type
of graph, what you want
to be able to do is to detect
that this negative cycle
exists.
And you're going
to, essentially,
say if this vertex
is v1, for example,
you want to be able to say delta
u v1 is undefined and similarly
for v2, v3, et cetera.
For all of these things,
the shortest path lengths
are undefined because
you can essentially
run through this negative
cycle any number of times
and get whatever shortest
path weight you want.
For this node, let's call
that v0, we have delta u v0
equals 2.
And there's a simple
path of length 1
in this case that
gets you from u to v0.
You don't encounter a cycle
or negative cycle in between.
So that's cool.
All right?
And of course, if you have
a vertex over here, z,
that can't be reached
from u then we're
going to have delta
uz being infinity.
And you can assume at the
beginning of these algorithms
that the source-- in this
case, I call the source u--
but the shortest
path to u would be 0.
And all of the other
ones are infinity.
And some of them
may stay infinity.
Some of them may obtain
finite shortest path weights.
And some of them
will be undefined
if you have a graph with
negative cycles in it.
So that's sort of the
specification, if you will,
of the requirements on the
Bellman-Ford algorithm.
We want it to be able to do all
of the things I just described.
OK?
So let's take a second look
at our generic shortest path
algorithm that I put up,
I think, about a week ago.
And this is a good
review of our notation.
But there are a
couple more things
I want to say about
this algorithm
that I didn't get to last time.
So you're given a graph and
you set all of the vertices
in the graph to have
infinite shortest path
weights, initially.
Set the predecessors to be null.
And then we'll set
d of s to be 0.
That's your source.
And the main loop would
be something like repeat,
select, and edge.
And we have a particular
way of selecting this edge.
And we have positive
edge weights
that corresponds to
the minimum priority.
And we talked about
Dijkstra but we have, maybe,
different ways of doing that.
We have to select
an edge somehow.
And then, we relaxed that edge.
u, v, w.
And you know about
the relaxation step.
I won't bother writing
it out right now.
But it's basically
something where
you look at the value
of d v. And if d v
is greater than d u plus the
weight, you relax the edge.
And you keep doing this.
The other thing that
you do in the relaxation
is to set the predecessor
pointers to be correct.
And that's part of
the relax routine.
And you keep doing this until
you can't relax anymore.
All right?
So that's our generic
shortest path algorithm.
There are two problems
with this algorithm.
The first, which we talked
about and both of these
have to do with the
complexity but the first one
is that the complexity
could be exponential time,
even for positive edge weights.
And the particular
example we talked about
was something where you had an
exponential number of paths.
And if you had a graph
that looks like this,
then it's possible that a
pathological selection of edges
is going to make you relax edges
an exponential number of times.
And in particular, if you
have n nodes in this graph,
it's plausible that
you'd end up getting
the complexity of order
2 raised to n over 2.
OK?
So that's one problem.
The second problem,
which is actually
a more obvious problem, is that
this algorithm might not even
terminate if this--
actually will not
terminate the way it's written
if there's a negative weight
cycle reachable from the source.
All right, so
there's two problems.
We fixed the first one.
In the case of positive
edges are non-negative edges.
We have a neat algorithm that
is an efficient algorithm called
Dijkstra that we talked
about last time that fixed
the first part.
But we don't know
yet how we're going
to handle negative cycles
in the general case.
We know how to
handle negative edges
in the case of a DAG-- a
directed acyclic graph--
but not in the general case.
OK?
So there's this great little
skit from Saturday Night Live
from the 1980s-- so way before
your time-- called The Five
Minute University.
Anybody seen this?
All right.
Look it up on YouTube.
Don't look it up during
lecture but afterwards.
So the character
here is a person
by the name of-- I
forget his real name
but his fake name is
Father Guido Sarducci.
All right?
So what's this Five
Minute University about?
Five Minute University,
he's selling this notion
and he says, look, five
years after you graduate
you, essentially, are
going to remember nothing.
OK?
I mean, you're not going
to remember anything
about all the courses
you took, et cetera.
So why waste your time on a
college education or waste
money-- $100,000-- on
a college education?
You know, for $20 I'll teach
you in five minutes what you're
going to remember five
years after you graduate.
All right?
So let's take it to an extreme.
Here's a 30 second
version up 6006.
And this is what I want you to
remember five years or 10 years
or whatever after you graduate.
All right?
And maybe the 10 second version
as polynomial time is great.
OK?
Exponential time is bad.
And infinite time
gets you fired.
OK?
So that's all you
need to remember.
No, that's all you need
to remember for the final.
This happens, you know, five
years after you graduate.
So you need to remember
a lot more if you
want to take your quiz next
week and the final exam.
But I think that
summarized over here.
You have a generic
shortest path algorithm.
And you realize that
if you do this wrong
you could very easily
get into a situation
where a polynomial
time algorithm, and we
know one for Dijkstra,
turns into exponential time
in the worst case, you
know, for a graph like that
because you're
selecting edges wrongly.
And in particular, that's
problem number one.
And problem number
two is if you have
a graph that isn't
what you expect.
In this case, let's say
you expected that a graph
with no negative cycles or maybe
not even negative edges in it.
You could easily
get into a situation
where your termination
condition is such
that your algorithm
never completes.
So we need to fix
problem number two today
using this algorithm
called Bellman-Ford.
And as it turns
out, this algorithm
is incredibly straightforward.
I mean, its complexity
we'll have to look at.
But from a description
standpoint,
it's four lines of code.
And let me put that up.
So Bellman-Ford takes a graph,
weights, and a source s.
And you can assume an adjacency
list specification of the graph
or the representation
of the graph.
And we do some initialization.
It's exactly the same
as in the generic case
except the d values will still
be looking at the d values
and talking about the
relaxation operation.
So we do an initialization.
And then, this algorithm
has multiple passes
because for I equals
1 to v minus 1.
So it does v minus 1 passes
roughly order v passes
where v is the
number of vertices.
And in each of these passes for
each edge u v belonging to e
relaxes every edge.
And just so everyone remembers,
relax u, v, w is if d of v
is greater than d of u plus w
u v then we'll set d v to be--
and we also set pi v to be u.
OK.
That's relax
operation over here.
So that's the algorithm.
And if you know
magically that they're
no negative cycles in the graph.
So if they're no negative
cycles in the graph,
then after these-- we'll
have to prove this.
But after these v
minus 1 passes you're
going to get the correct
shortest pathways.
OK?
You want to do a
little bit more, right?
I motivated what we
want Bellman-Ford to do
earlier in the lecture.
So you can also do a check.
So you may not know if they're
negative weight cycles or not.
But at this point,
you can say I'm
going to do one more pass
so the v path-- the v
is the number of
vertices-- over the graph.
So for each edge in the graph,
if you do one more relaxation
and you see that d v is
greater than d u plus w u v. So
you're not doing a relaxation.
You're doing a check to see
if you can relax the edge.
Then report minus v
negative cycle exists.
So this is the check.
And the first part
is the computation.
So that's kind of neat.
I mean, it fit's on a board.
We talk about the correctness.
The functionality,
I hope everyone got.
Do people understand
what's happening here
with respect to functionality?
Any questions?
Not about correctness
but functionality?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Where
does the [INAUDIBLE]
get used in the formula?
PROFESSOR: Oh, it doesn't.
It's just a counter
that makes sure
that you do v minus 1 passes.
So what's that complexity
of this algorithm
using the best data structure
that we can think of?
Anyone?
Yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] v plus e
if you're using a [INAUDIBLE]
to access [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: v plus e?
AUDIENCE: Or v e plus e.
PROFESSOR: So that would be?
AUDIENCE: That's
using a dictionary?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I know.
v e plus e would be?
That's correct but.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
But I mean when do v e plus
e you can ignore the e.
So say you have just v times e.
All right.
Good.
Here you go.
So this part here is v times e.
And it doesn't really matter.
I mean, you can use an array
structure adjacency list.
It's not like Dijkstra where
we have this neat requirement
for a priority queue and
there's different ways
of implementing
the priority queue.
This part would be order of v e.
And that gives you the
overall complexity.
This part here is only one
pass through the edges.
So that's order
e, like you said.
So the complexities order v e.
And this could be large, as
I said before in, I think,
the first lecture.
e is order of v square
in a simple graph.
So you might end up with
a v cubed complexity
if you run Bellman-Ford.
So there's no question
that Bellman-Ford
is, from a practical
standpoint, substantially slower
than Dijkstra.
You can get Dijkstra down
to linear complexity.
But this would potentially,
at least in terms of vertices,
be cubic complexity.
So when you have a chance,
you want to use Dijkstra.
And you're forced
to use Bellman-Ford
because you could potentially
have negative weight
cycles while you're
stuck with that.
All right?
OK, so why does this work?
This looks a bit like magic.
It turns out we can actually do
a fairly straightforward proof
of correctness of Bellman-Ford.
And we're going
to do two things.
We're going to not only
show that if negative weight
cycles don't exist that
this will correctly
compute shorter stats.
But we also have to show that
it will detect negative weight
cycles if they in fact exist.
So there's two parts to this.
And let's start.
So what we have here
for this algorithm
is that it can guarantee
in a graph g equals
v E. If it contains no
negative weight cycles then
after Bellman-Ford
finishes execution,
d v equals delta s v for all
v belonging to v. All right?
And then there's that.
That's the theorem
you want to prove.
And the second piece
of it is corollary
that we want to prove.
And that has to
do with the check.
And this says if
a value of d of v
fails to converge
after v minus 1
passes there exists a negative
weight cycle reachable from s.
So those are the two things
that we need to show.
I'll probably take a few
minutes to do each of these.
That theorem is a
little more involved.
So one of the first
things that we
have to do in order
to prove this theorem
is to think about exactly what
the shortest path corresponds
to in a generic sense.
So when we have source
vertex s and you have
a particular vertex
v then there's
the picture that we need
to keep in mind as we try
and prove this theorem.
So you have v0, v1, v2, et
cetera all the way to vk.
This is my vertex v. This is s.
So s equals v0.
V equals vk.
All right?
So I'm going to have a path p.
That is v0, v1,
all the way to vk.
OK?
How big is k in the worst case?
How big is k?
Anybody?
It's up on the black board.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: v minus 1, right?
Why?
What would happen if k
is larger than v minus 1?
I'd have a cycle.
I'd be visiting a
vertex more than once.
And it wouldn't
be a simple path.
Right?
So k is less than or equal to v
minus 1 else I'd have a cycle.
OK?
I wouldn't have a simple path.
And we're looking for the
shortest, simple paths
because if you ever
get to the point
where-- why are we looking
for shortest, simple paths?
Well, in this
case, we're looking
for shortest, simple paths.
And if there's a
negative cycle, we're
in trouble because the
shortest path is not
necessarily the simple
path because you
could go around the
cycle a bunch of times.
I'll get back to that.
But in the case where we're
trying to prove the theorem,
we know that no
negative cycles exist.
We can assume that
no negative cycles
exist for the case
of the theorem.
And we want to show that
Bellman-Ford correctly
computes each of the
shortest path weights.
And in that case, there's
no negative weight cycles.
We're guaranteed that k is less
than or equal to v minus 1.
All right?
Everybody buy that?
Good.
All right.
So that's the picture I
want you keep in mind.
Let's dive in and
prove this theorem.
And we prove it using induction.
So let v be any vertex.
And let's say that
we're looking at a path.
v0, v1, v2, to vk.
And like I said, from
v0 equals s to vk
equals v. And in
particular, I'm not
going to say that this
path p is a shortest
path with the minimum
number of edges.
So there may be
many shortest paths.
And I'm going to
pick the one that
has the minimum number of edges.
If there's a unique shortest
path, then that's a given.
But it may be that I have
a path with four edges that
has the same weight as
another path with three edges.
I'm going to pick the
one that has three edges.
OK?
So it may not be
unique with respect
that they're not necessarily
unique shortest paths.
But I can certainly pick one.
And no negative weight cycles
implies that p is simple.
And that implies that k is less
than or equal to v minus 1,
which is what I just argued.
Now keep in mind that picture
over there to the right.
And basically, the argument
is going to go as follows.
Remember that I'm
going to be relaxing
every edge in each
pass of the algorithm.
OK?
There's no choices here.
I'm going be relaxing every edge
in each pass of the algorithm.
And essentially, the
proof goes as follows.
I'm going to be moving
closer and closer to vk
and constructing this
shortest path at every pass.
So at some point
in the first pass,
I'm going to relax
this edge v0, v1.
OK?
And at that point, thanks to the
optimal substructure property,
given that this is
the shortest path,
this has to be a
shortest path, as well.
Any subset of the shortest
path has to be a shortest path.
I'm going to relax
this edge and I'm
going to get the value
of delta from s to v1.
And it's going to be
this relaxation that's
going to get me that value.
And after the first pass, I'm
going to be able to get to v1.
After the second
pass, I can get to v2.
And after k passes, I'm going
to be able to get to vk.
So I'm just growing this
frontier one node every pass.
And that's your induction.
And you can write that out.
And I'll write it out here.
But that's basically it.
So after one pass through all
of the edges e, we have d of v1
to be delta s v1.
And the reason for this
is because we'll relax.
We're guaranteed to
relax all the edges.
And we'll relax the edge
v0, v1 during this pass.
And we can't find a
shorter path than this path
because, otherwise we'd violate
the optimum substructure
property.
And that means that
it's a contradiction
that we selected a shortest
path in the first place.
So can argue that we have delta
s v1 after the first pass.
And this goes on.
I'm going to write
out this proof
because I think it's
important for you guys
to see the full proof.
But you can probably guess
the rest at this point.
After one pass,
that's what you get.
After two passes
through e we have
d v2 equals delta s v2
because in the second pass
we're going to
relax edge v1, v2.
So it' a different edge
that needs to be relaxed.
But that's cool because
I'm relaxing all the edges.
And I'm going to be able
to grow my frontier.
I'm going to be able to
compute delta s v2 and the end
of my second pass and
so on and so forth.
So after k passes, we have
d vk equals delta s vk.
And if I run through v
minus 1 passes, which
is what I do in the algorithm,
all reachable vertices
have delta values.
All right?
That's basically it.
Any questions?
It's actually a simpler proof
than the Dijkstra proof,
which I just sketched last time.
I'll just give
you some intuition
of the Dijkstra proof.
It's probably a little too
painful to do in a lecture.
But this one is, as you can
see, nice and clean and fits
on two boards, which is kind
of an important criterion here.
So good.
All right, so that takes
care of the theorem.
Hopefully you're all on
board with the theorem.
And one thing that we haven't
done is talk about the check.
So the argument with
respect to the corollary
bootstraps this particular
argument for the theorem.
But this requires the
insight that if after v
minus 1 passes, if you can find
an edge that can be relaxed,
well what does that mean?
So at this point, let's say that
I've done my v minus 1 passes
and we find an edge
that can be relaxed.
Well, this means that the
current shortest path from s
to some vertex that is
obviously reachable v
is not simple once I've
relaxed this edge because I
have a repeated vertex.
So that means it's not simple
to have a repeated vertex that's
the same as I found a cycle.
And it's a negative
weight cycle because I
was able to relax the edge
and reduce the weight after I
added a vertex
that cost a cycle.
All right?
So this cycle has to
be negative weight.
Found a cycle that
is negative weight.
All right.
That's pretty much it.
So it's, I guess,
a painful algorithm
from a standpoint of it's
not particularly smart.
It's just relaxing
all of the edges
a certain fixed number of times.
And it just works out because
you will find these cycles.
And if you keep going, it's
like this termination condition.
What is neat is that I don't
have the generic shortest path
algorithm up there anymore.
But in effect,
what you're saying
is after a certain
number of passes,
if you haven't
finished, you can quit
because you have found
a negative cycle.
So it's very similar to
the generic shortest path
algorithm.
You're not really
selecting the edges.
You're selecting all
of them, in this case.
And you're running through
a bunch of different passes.
All right?
So that's it with
respect to Bellman-Ford.
I want to do a couple
of special cases
and revisit the
directed acyclic graph.
But stop me here if you have any
questions about Bellman-Ford.
You first and then back there.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Maybe
I'm just confused
about the definition of a cycle.
But if you had, like, a tree,
which had a negative weight
edge, wouldn't it produce
the same situation
where you relaxed that edge.
PROFESSOR: But you would have
relaxed that edge previously.
AUDIENCE: But it wouldn't
be a cycle, right?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it
wouldn't be a cycle.
So let's look at that.
That's a fine question.
AUDIENCE: Doesn't
that make assumptions
about this structure?
PROFESSOR: Well if you
had a tree-- I mean,
a tree is a really simple case.
But if you had
something like this
and if you did have
a minus 1 edge here,
right-- we'll do a more
complicated example.
But let's say you had
something like this.
2 3 minus 1.
And what will happen is if this
happens to be your s vertex
and in the first step
you relax all the edges.
And this one would get two.
And then, depending on the
order in which you relaxed,
it's quite possible that if
you relax this edge first--
let's say in the first pass
the ordering of the relaxation
is 1, 2, and 3.
So the edges are ordered
in a certain way each time,
and you're going to be
relaxing the edges in exactly
the same order each time.
All right?
It doesn't matter.
The beauty of Bellman-Ford
is that-- let's say
you relax this edge.
Initially, this is at infinity.
So this is at 0.
This is at infinity.
If you relax this
edge, nothing happens.
All right?
Then you relax, let's say, this
edge because that's number two.
This gets set to two.
You relax this edge
because that's 3.
And this is infinity
so nothing happens.
Of course, this is already at
two so nothing would happen.
So the end of the first pass,
what you have is this is 0.
That's 2.
This is still infinity.
That's still infinity.
OK?
That's going to stay infinity
because you can't reach it
from s.
So we can, sort of, ignore that.
And then, of the second
pass, what you have is
you start with this edge again
because that's the ordering.
And this 2 minus 1
would give this a 1.
And then you relax this edge
or try to relax this edge.
Nothing happens.
Try to relax this edge.
And at this point,
you have one more pass
to go because you
got 4 vertices.
And in that past,
nothing changes again.
So that's what you end up with.
You end up with 2 for
this and 1 for that.
OK?
That makes sense?
So the important
thing to understand
is that you are
actually relaxing
all of the edges in every pass.
And there's a slightly
more complicated example
than this that is in the notes.
And you can take a
look at that offline.
There's another
question in the back.
Did you have a question?
Someone raised their hand.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Yes,
I'm just curious--
is there a unknown
better algorithm that
can do the same thing?
PROFESSOR: No, there's
no known better algorithm
for solving the
general case like this.
There are a couple of
algorithms that assume weights
within a certain range.
And then there complexities
include both v and e, as well
as w where w is the dynamic
range of the weights.
And depending on
what w is, you could
argue that they have
better complexity.
But they're kind of
incomparable in the sense
that they have this
extra parameter, which
is the dynamic range of the w.
OK?
Now there's lots
of special cases,
like I said, and well take a
look at the DAG special case
in a second where you
could imagine doing better
but not for the case where you
have an arbitrary graph that
could have negative cycles in it
because it's got negative rate
edges.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: In the
corollary, does that assume
you have a connected
graph because, you know,
you could have a
negative weight edge
in a separate part
of the graph, which
isn't reachable from this.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So you're going to start when
you have an undefined weight.
Remember your
initialization condition.
What is affected by s?
Initialize is affected by s.
The rest of it
isn't affected by s
because you're just
relaxing the edges.
Initialize is affected
by s because d of s
starts out being 0, like I put
over here, and the rest of them
are infinity.
So there is an effect of the
choice of the starting vertex.
And the rest of it
follows that you
will get an undefined
value, or you
will find that
negative cycle exists
based on whether you can
reach it from s or not.
So if you happen to
have s over here,
and it's just the
one node, and then
it has no edges going
out of it, this algorithm
would just be trivial.
But it wouldn't detect
any negative cycles
that aren't reachable from s.
That make sense?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: So there is this--
it's kind of hidden over there.
So I'm glad you
asked that question.
But initialize is
setting things up.
And that is something
that affects
the rest of the algorithm
because d of s is 0
and the rest of them
are set to infinity.
All right?
So if there are no
other questions,
I'll move on to
the case of the DAG
and talk a little bit about
shortest paths versus longest
paths.
And this is somewhat of
a preview of a lecture
that Eric is going to give a
month from now on complexity
and the difference between
polynomial time and exponential
time, though I'm not going
to go into much depth here.
But there's some
interesting relationships
between the shortest path
problem and the longest path
problem that I'd like to get to.
But any other questions on this?
OK, so let me ask a question.
Suppose I wanted to find
longest paths in a graph
and let's say that this graph
had all positive edge weights.
OK.
What if I negated all
of the edge weights
and ran a Bellman-Ford?
Would I find the longest
path in the graph?
Do people understand
the question?
I don't need this.
So maybe we can talk about what
a longest path means first.
So if this was s and this v1,
v2, v3, fairly straightforward,
you know how to compute
shortest paths now.
These are all positive.
Even easier.
The longest path
to v3 is of length.
Six because I go here, go
there, and go there, right?
So that's my longest path.
OK?
And the shortest path
to v3 is of length 4.
So shortest path, longest
paths, have these nice duality.
What if I said,
well, you know, I
can solve the longest
path problem, as well,
given all of what I've
learned about shortest paths
simply by negating each of these
edges and running Bellman-Ford.
What would happen?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] shortest
path branch [INAUDIBLE]
values, and if you
switched to absolute value,
it will give you
the longest path.
PROFESSOR: So you
think it works?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
It will also check the cycles.
So the negative cycles will be
the longest path cycles that
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: But I think
that's the key question.
What will Bellman-Ford do
when it is run on this?
What would it return?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: No, what will
Bellman-Ford return?
I'm asking.
Someone else?
What will Bellman-Ford
return if I ran this?
Undefined.
Right?
Undefined because you got this
negative weight cycle here.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
Oh!
Let's put another one in there.
Oops, sorry.
Now I see.
You're right.
I'm wrong.
And why did you say undefined?
AUDIENCE: I was wrong.
PROFESSOR: OK, good.
I got company.
Thank you.
Good.
Let's take it all over again.
All over again.
All right.
All right, start over.
s v1 v2 v3.
Yeah, that is a cycle.
All right, good.
Cycle.
So when you actually
negate each of these edges,
you end up with a
negative weight cycle.
So it's plausible that you
could have a graph like this one
where this strategy won't
work because what would happen
is Bellman-Ford would come back
with, essentially, an abort
that says I can't compute
shortest paths because they're
undefined.
All right?
Now it turns out it's actually
more subtle than that.
What we're trying to do in
Bellman-Ford is, in the case
where negative weight
cycles don't exist,
we report on the
shortest simple path.
That's the whole
notion of the proof.
We say that the path has
a certain length, which
is, at most, v minus 1
and so on and so forth.
We get the shortest simple path.
But if you actually have a
problem where you say-- let
me start over again.
Let's say I want to find
the shortest simple path
for a different
graph and it happens
to have a negative
weight cycle in it.
So I have something like this.
2 3 minus 6, 3 over here,
3 over here, and so on.
Maybe 2 here.
And I want to find the
shortest simple path that
reaches v from s.
OK?
What is the shortest simple
path that reaches v from s?
It's this path that
goes horizontally,
which has a weight
3 plus 2, 5, 5
plus 3, 8, 8 plus 3,
11, 11 plus 2, 13.
All right?
So the shortest
simple path is 13.
Will Bellman-Ford give you any
information about this path?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: No because
in [INAUDIBLE].
After it does its v minus 1
passes, v is reachable from s.
But you potentially go through
a negative weight cycle
before you reach v. OK?
So it turns out that if you have
a graph with negative weight
cycles, finding the
shortest simple path
is an NP-hard problem.
It's a really hard problem.
That's what NP means.
No, it means something
else that Eric
will explain to you
in a month or so.
But it means that we don't
know any algorithm that
is better than exponential
time to solve this problem.
OK?
So amazingly, all you've done is
taken the shortest path problem
and changed it ever so slightly.
You said I want to look for
the shortest simple path
in the general case where
I could, potentially,
have negative weight
cycles in my graph.
And when you do that,
all bets are off.
You're not in the polynomial
time complexity domain anymore.
At least, not that we know of.
And the best that you can do is
an exponential time algorithm
to find shorter simple paths.
And this problem,
as it turns out,
is equivalent to the longest
path problem in the sense
that they're both NP-hard.
If you can solve one, you
could solve the other.
So to summarize, what
happens here simply
is that in the case
of Bellman-Ford
running on the original
shortest path problem,
you're allowed to abort when
you detect the fact that there's
a negative cycle.
So given that you're allowed
to abort when there's
a negative cycle, you have
a polynomial time solution
using Bellman-Ford
that is not necessarily
going to give you shortest
path weights but will
in the case of no
negative cycles.
All right?
But if you ask for more-- a
little bit more-- you said,
you know, it'd be great
if you could somehow
process these negative
cycles and tell me
that if I had a simple path and
I don't go through cycles what
would the shortest
weight be, it becomes
a much more difficult problem.
It goes from order
of ve complexity
to exponential time complexity
to the best of our knowledge.
So that's what I'd
like to leave you with.
That there's much more to
algorithms than just the ones
that we're looking at.
And we get a little
bit of a preview
of this-- so the difference
between polynomial time
an exponential time--
later on in the term.